but right before I was about to click
stop or start streaming Guiness man 1970
subscribed thanks goodness man 1970 so
we're gonna do some puzzle rush I was
not planning to stream today but then
some free time opened up this is going
to be a brief stream but let's try and
beat Josh Reed oh it's a monster 49
didn't know he was so good at puzzles
okay we're gonna start and focus
probably take a night or take a push-up
take a queen
take a rock and mates mates it's moving
to let's turn down the volume it's made
into free nights free King pretty king
pretty look oh no oh mouse slip ugh okay
slow down and focus Bishop takes e4 and
when a queen check and win a rook taken
mates eventually when a queen when a
Knights take and win something can
probably do this and take let's take
here inmates
where is the win I mean I can win the
night okay when the night here Chuck
Chuck Chuck Nate opposition another
slaughtered mates mmm
Queen c1 maybe or a chopped the Queen
rook b1 traps of Queen take the knight
or a 5 b 4 as a fork mmm
let's run this way huh okay I know that
was new it was gonna be a fork somewhere
there rook here looks nice check in wait
check King g8 take the bishop maybe or
take the rook can push and then take and
then Queen this is just back oh it's a
pin so I check and then do this it's
nice check anything better
let's check first check and mate
so I check King h2 I'm not seeing
anything clear maybe Queen a5 there or
if I I don't know
hey it's bits 1111 from Nile Homer but
I'm trying to focus
what's the move here Queen f5 but then
Queen f3
then Queen b1 no I mouse slipped oh this
is the second now slip in a row or not
in a row but of this puzzle rush this is
a famous one right it's 96 and then this
and then g4 his mates it's got to be
this and then promote to rook probably
or do I now I have to promote care
promotes a queen it's got to be rook and
then where's this looks long maybe this
and then mate I mean should have
something here regressive in looks
decent
oh maybe this and then check okay
takes Bishop e5 easy takes maybe check
first it's gotta be and then Queen a1
could be a move and then where is it
Chuck nice Queen here gotta be a 5
oh not a 5
okay well 39 puts me in wait
this is hourly wait do I finish high an
hourly refresh hey I'm tied for first in
the hourly it's not bad I thought Josh
Reed L was up there but maybe that was
another list thanks cover for something
seven months Nile Homer what's the
significance with eleven eleven it's not
November 11th
it's February 24th hello to people in
the chats double haze all caps hey music
man torques can sagar sour dusts lots of
people Canadian historian Braden
Laughlin Belgium novice and sugar
okay let's do another one I have to
finish my chocolate before I can talk
what is this one Oh Nathan one okay I
can talk again let's take the night and
take the rook
let's take their check and mate I have
to be very careful in Mouse slipping my
mouse is over enthusiastic today I can
take I can check I can play b6 what's
the move here why am I not seeing it
Brooke I faith I mean it's logical Queen
I'm I'm baffled I mean I got a stop
knight f7 so let's do it okay
check and mate take a rook take a
another Brooke take a queen oh my queen
was hanging there he's moving too fast
have to not lose Chuck check and check
and mate
Chuck intake can push and pushing in Oh
take the Knights
let's take Chuck and win the Queen to
check threatening mate on each one so
Chuck takes that's got to be check
oh no wait no it's this check ok takes
and there should be five take some mates
five looks good this looks decent
checking eight shapes
ah this is even more decent this is nice
check
I want to take on d4 it's more bits to
focus so takes take some d4 again I'm
not seeing anything entirely clear let's
take on d4 no let's try this this and
this and this and this
what Oh No Queen takes 83 was made into
Queen B 2 was made in 1 I was
unfortunate thanks for the bits cover
just add blue I steel is nuts
is that a Nakamura reference promoting
nuts
haha I'll be in st. Louis hopefully next
month next month is like in 6 days I'll
probably be coming by for US
Championships Canadian history perfect
way to spend your night I mean if you're
in Canada it should not be nighttime yet
but it's approaching nighttime tour skin
from Norway not sure how to pronounce
the last part of that Tryg V I know
absolutely zero Norwegian thankfully
most are regions no English
ah at 6 p.m. in some time zone okay
Oh Canada uses a different Sun feel
about that okay uh let's play again 26
was terrible
I've lost my spot on the leaderboard and
I'm in now in fourth place okay
going again mates hey it's another sub
stew what is your name Stu tada
take a rook take that take that take
that
do this and win
listen win this looks nice what color am
i I'm white
so just attack the pin piece check and
mate check check and win check on g6 and
takes mate take this and when the Queen
should be made into this is a winning
material this is mate is it mate I'm
winning the night
let's take this and where's my mate
Bishop here I have to draw this
maybe this I'll to take knacks queen g4
looking for a mate I mean I could win
the night but where's the mate G for us
o Queen h6 and end
okay one do something fancy night g3 92
mm and I could take on d6 just when that
it's taken Queen e5 I win the rook I
guess I had Queen b8 no okay what is
this check you this is nice
Ice Queen sack this looks nice
of check inmates Queen f6 Queen d8 and
then rook eight keeps going I could take
the rook take the Queen this well how do
i trap the Queen h5 queen is free Bishop
c8 or Bishop see it right away
h5 first probably men bishops eh I could
push up on down he takes with check or
she I could take the bishop
check check check raise a mate I can
maybe chop the Queen chops a queen right
nice this looks decent no night is it
really this could be Wow
it's gotta be taking the nitrites really
I just was guessing there's an educated
guess what is this problem
ah it's check ah that's nice I can't
draw arrows but it's my III Bishop takes
takes takes and stalemates okay 32 it's
something more people are in the chats
Samsonite in the chat El Capitan PDX
with subbing 100 bits puzzles
exclamation points I don't understand
this capital F like what does capital F
stand for or symbolize I know it's like
some other game but how like is it
doesn't mean fail okay
I know this is a big difference between
puzzle ratings on me chasse and chasse
calm yeah different sites have different
rating algorithms it's more about just
doing puzzles and learning I think like
I did a stream a few months ago right I
think I discovered that like some of the
leech ass and chest comm puzzles like
overlap but it would be nice if if leech
s had its own puzzle rush to and
apparently chess comm is gonna have like
a puzzle rush battle as far as I heard I
don't know when it's gonna be released
over you like battle someone press f to
pay respects o when someone dies that's
nice okay I thought that was our IP okay
new puzzle rush take a look take a
bishop fork mate
night checkmate mate mate mate Knights
disappear and when the bishop fork
check
was this check there I could win the
rook I mean there's a real got7 let's
just take a look when a queen Knight g5
take the bishop take the Knights I could
take the night but then I lose take the
knight this way take the bishop this way
work skewer trap I chopped the Queen
that's nice
what does this take on b2 it should be
for the England gambits is this some
weird mate or I just win the Queen okay
rook b2 looks attractive King age seven
okay rook e8 looks attractive I could I
have a few moves here could take the
knight throw a 95 check if you like
taking the Knights yeah the Queen h4 is
a move c4 is a move let's play C for
check-in win the Knights take the
Knights take the pawn lots of targets
here takes maybe it's tapes and rook g5
or just that takes and check and mate
the nights of targets 94 is a move 94
looks nice and then I take and fork
Chuck
I mean it's gotta be Chuck where's the
mates is their mates take on d1 some
weird night move takes night there there
there
oh I'm just winning material okay take
the bishop maybe trap the Queen just
look for mates
ah maybe no 26 I'm not seeing it
play Queen c3 and then take know Queenie
to the threats what is it I have to stop
Queenie - I could take the bishop maybe
now okay Knight there or maybe Queen
here that's nice
takes probably inmates Queen it's gotta
be Queen's III unless it's something
else what is it
Queen somewhere night somewhere maybe
just this Wow okay and going to slowly
maybe this and this check broke up 122
ideas check no it's gotta be check right
or is it some clerk maybe it's a fork no
not enough time I could take the rook no
this has got to be winning
wait takes okay there we go
9:05 no okay 37 that's something not
quite 39 not quite 55 those naka still
have the record oh yeah naka still has a
record my covering PCL this week I'm not
sure actually it's on Tuesday I'll be
free during that time at least during
the windmill match but I don't know if
I'll be in a quiet place with Wi-Fi if I
am I'll stream it if I'm not I'll watch
it and do Twitter but yeah I'm actually
traveling like in a half hour
going to Wisconsin so they ask sometimes
it's hard to predict the stream
conditions when I travel
wait what okay I I missed some old
comments I don't know if I guessed too
much press f to pay respects okay I
think I understand that now ah so you
were challenging me to two drafts
earlier yeah I I logged onto the site
because I was curious if it's still up I
saw there they're hosting like some
World Championship yeah whenever you
challenge or whenever like I got the
challenge I was a little bit busy like I
was about to start a private lesson I do
need to to get back to drafts cuz I
played drops in Africa against these
these kids in some small village because
chess was a bit too difficult anyway
no draws for this fame this will be
puzzle rush do I do one more to finish
my team and my sugar chocolate is just
like really nicely flavored sugar okay
let's do one more again I won't talk
until I finish my chocolate
hmm what's this Queen b6 haha I have to
remember that chess is played with the
minds and not the mouse so I work with
kids they try and like they play with
their hands and not the her brain ones
this and maybe just take this man that's
okay Oh Chuck I'll win the Queen or all
mates
let's take there and then this and then
this and then this take the Knights
black threatening something but is it
anything maybe just take 23 teensy to
Queen B to King g3 check well it's very
risky but what else do I do
okay somehow it works
I have to do this maybe perpetual ah oh
I had some pawn push terrible check
I mean I have a you know I don't have a
fork h4 okay
it's taking push whoa okay
oh that's nice
taking 25 so weights running some mate
so Bishop g5 before maybe rook a e1 it's
taken win check or check maybe this
check my mates okay I could push
ah push push and then when you take your
defend with the bishop so I'm getting
forked I have to not lose material is
there any counter-attack
maybe this we trade pushing got three
probably or f3 immediately for Queen g2
immediately maybe just perpetual oh I
want a ruck okay mm maybe this move
any threats of chucks oh just meat okay
I mean I could stop the pawn by coming
back that way
I rock up one gonna try it and then
maybe this keeps going Chuck there we go
Queen g8 me just keep checking until
it's mates okay
check check check mates I want to break
so forty no I should have taken the
bishop first okay Gigi that's rough 39
it's not enough time towards the end
there
toriel noggin my package did arrive but
I'm gonna keep it a mystery I recorded
myself opening it and I wanna like I
want to make a youtube video for those
who don't know which is everyone apart
from the toilet noggin I received a
package from an anonymous fan was it
anonymous fan yeah an honest fan first
package I've ever received from liking
anyone random online and I opened it a
little while ago I have the Box
boxes somewhere I'll be posting a
YouTube video soon thanks to whoever
gave it to me which could be any number
of people may be lurking in the chat
also thanks to last relic for the sub
and squishy squishy Hercules do I
usually call squishy squirrels because I
can't read
thanks for the hundred bits there is a
message there decent work mr. Rosen
bunny mania you saw my marathon videos
it's been a while since I've done a
marathon video you had chocolate chip
banana bread today I've had chocolate
chips today I still have some we're
running out okay let's do another one
mmm check the ones I missed whoa it's so
small now this one I was supposed to
push the pong yeah and then meeting
I don't why it's so small maybe they're
testing my vision if I can see properly
I had to do a vision test a few days ago
because I lost my driver's license I had
to renew it and I was so nervous because
the letters were so small and I couldn't
distinguish between the D and the O so I
just guessed I was squinting really hard
I think I guess correctly because they
said I passed a queen wait what was this
I don't even oh I took the bishop maybe
no remember this one
what does Bishop d2 what is this
Oh defending c3 I understand
mm-hmm okay
oops nervously chess puzzle rush and the
last one oh the last few were just chaos
oh yeah toilet noggin I've I have I did
like it I've actually used it twice
today and it's something that I've used
it like other places that I've never
like had myself but it's it actually has
a practical purpose so anyway let's do
another one
okay want to get through the first ones
quickly it's all about time management
like doing the ones quickly first and
then slowing down later to prioritize
accuracy for when when what does this
fork makes me oh no that was not me it's
got to his mate takes him here check and
clean smothered mates
check that was actually double check
pretty Bishop King e5 so bold take some
fork it's taken mate
Bishop here looks good h5 has got to be
mates
let's move the Queen somewhere can move
the Queen to some square really move it
h3 maybe takes ok no it's a move
maybe this first and then this is Rikai
fates free queen or no I take here and
then free Queen mmm a force gotta be mmm
do this it's got to be some quiet move
or some loud move maybe you work here
just take ok
I could take check or clift now do this
and take baby oh do I just draw I can't
draw anything better don't see it okay I
could take ok I take in Queen d4 and
fork 3 oh my Queens hanging so check and
then mates Queen seafloor is obvious but
is it right and queenside castling
probably
ah before maybe taking away c5 but then
Knight g5 and then c5 mates
okay 35 with two minutes but I've
already missed two f5 probably mmm maybe
Queen here I put them Bishop e2 so maybe
here okay which way are the pawns going
takes and it's a race wait
takes takes push push okay okay
I should see three probably almost like
check first god oh wait there should see
three there's Queen off for Bishop d2
maybe then Bishop c3 nice mmm Queen f6
is this maybe rook c1 looks sketchy
though Queen f6
not seeing it takes it he just takes and
something what was it chat help me
black to move what's my highest score 44
but actually it's 43 with me just doing
it alone
44 I had a few GM's helping me maybe I
can see like oh no okay Christopher you
such a monster with 48 so what is this
position Queen f6 didn't look right Rick
see one there's Queen take see one maybe
each Oh H five is forcing should have
considered take some Enric a fate
probably H five how do I test it h 5
yeah each 5 is a nice move okay
one more I got it go soon have some
driving to do oh there's people
suggesting moves I don't think anyone
suggested h5 bye to the ice thanks for
stopping by
ah the ice I saw your message I'll get
back to you via email or Skype or
something okay let's do one more play
again
ooh one more chocolate chip all right
mmm
that doesn't count okay pass 199 thanks
for subbing nine months all right focus
check check check
takes meat meat do this and this mate do
this and this and mate takes here
probably rook a1 probably this and
skewer in the end mmm maybe trap the
rook pork
cork the same pattern as before I play
the seamless missing this mmm where's my
queen what is this I could take the pawn
okay I probably work here oh I could
take and win the bishop was this what is
this
check check mate
okay check inmates takes probably this
when the rook okay lots of options I
could take on g7 super major paying with
us uh I could maybe play Knight c7 first
doesn't do much really
that's got to be winning material
somehow let's try this okay
you know 7s you meet nice and this this
is just a draw but how is it a draw
ah this it's nice
check check checkmate maybe this that's
gotta be and then what
ah this and then here and then meaning
they should a success a move taking as a
move
check as a move
maybe this okay
what's the move here chief no do
something maybe I for rookie six it's
gotta be right
I'd see four maybe check and me that was
you
oh no that's not easy Chuck maybe
have to meet otherwise I'm getting
needed okay classic one Scott it be
taking right
maybe this this okay takes or takes I'm
not sure let's try this
there we go take it could just be taking
looks too obvious
okay maybe this didn't make any sense
there mods in the chat should be nods in
the chat okay that may have been my last
one 37
I've been hovering like around the 30s I
peaked at 39 my Lois was my Lois was
actually to one of the previous ones I'm
almost out of chocolate chips hey we hit
200 subs a few weeks ago who a few weeks
ago we hit 400 subs and then I didn't
stream for like 10 days because I was in
Africa who is the 200 sub super major
pain was that you on your sub deserves
some reward
okay I'll do one more only one more hmm
what color am I
there we go well the basic tactics some
of these aren't even tactics just
winning free pieces or mating okay now
we're getting now this is still pretty
simple we're getting a little bit more
difficult 91
ah then I skewer maybe this is made into
can take this way fork what is this
Queen trade and then push
tf1 working waking up on uh check and
win the Queen on passant or is it it's
always on Toussaint
but then what battery could do this
takes g6 already miss - this is meeting
somehow
you
nice finish there it's always on pissant
right takes it takes first here and then
here nice this is nice to work out three
looks logical nice page six also move
Queeny - what next move there okay
give you this rook now rook takes a five
and the other move gotta be this and
then this and this it takes on g6 or as
it takes on each six takes on f8 b this
first
nah this is tough very tough I miss
something maybe I mix I miss something
well appreciate the existence of mods oh
there's even any mods in the chat but
thanks mods the Isle Homer cheering for
the mods that's great I have no idea
what I miss I'm playing the London
system as white and my black opponents
rarely plays c5 usually just 96 instead
is there some tactic for me to take
advantage of in professional games yeah
depends how early they play knight c6 if
they're playing the knight in front of
the C pawn let's just go tell me chess
answer a quick question actually and
I'll make a new study devoted to one
question black plays early a knight c6
in London
so what layout looks ok answering a
question so let's say you're playing
London also it depends on the move order
too but if they do something I really
like this I like to recommend like some
early c4 followed by this and this and
then this because they can't play c6 so
there's less ways black and support the
pawn and if they play e6 on their
bishops kind of stuck if their bishop
develops earlier than Queen b3 would hit
the pawn so that's just a kind of a
quick answer but hopefully that gives
you some starting points
Eric the $5,000 of board I sent you oh
did I give them did you send me $5,000
or was it five thousand bits
I have a video wait I was gonna post
something on YouTube I posted something
on my youtube story I wonder if it's
still there our YouTube has this like
story feature my channel stories I could
show a brief picture
hey month fella 77 yeah so I brought a
couple boards and pieces
I gave one into a small village with
like a lot of kids there's a picture
somewhere you find it I was trying to
teach them chess like they didn't know
the rules we were going over pawns and
then one of them like captured and like
it was checkers so then we started
playing checkers those more like troughs
yeah here's the picture people can see
so I might put together or clip together
some like some portions of the video for
youtube or something to show on Twitch
but I didn't I did my best to deliver
that I played soccer with them to have
some soccer video maybe I'll make some
like clip of soccer and chess
what about early C takes d4 in London
pawn takes pawn so another question
answering another question yeah I have a
feeling this question is referring to
the line which transposes into Carroll
Khan like takes takes like let's say
takes takes here here in Bishop f5 if
this is what you're asking about
Yusuke 47 usually you want to take with
you pawn you want to keep the file open
it's best for a block to develop the
bishop if black plays u6 then white has
very easy development usually you castle
you put the knight on e5 and that can
lead to some climb attack in the middle
game on the Kings side if black plays
Bishop f5 here you can play Queen b3
then it depends where the black Queen
goes black has to be a little bit
careful because if Queen d7 you have a
knife here a black is bad enough to take
then you you win something because you
have a double threat so I think most
players will play queen CH you can play
ninety to six and then there's a move
here if it's almost popular move oh this
night h4 hitting the bishop and you you
got the bishop here at bishop here you
play off three there's a g6 you oh you
can play g4
a game in this actually I remember
preparing for that game and like I just
turned on stockfish and actress was
recommending the setup what do I like to
play against King's gambit the other day
I played against Kings gambit I played
some really bizarre opening which is
probably not good but it's it's
interesting be six and then this this is
called the Belgium Belgium defense or
Belgian defense but if you want like a
more reliable recommendation personally
I like to play d5 after pawn takes I
like to take here and it's has a good
reputation also there's a chap white
takes this way there's Queen h4 winning
four black not expecting all these
questions I guess this is what happens
when I answer one random question I'll
get like five more random questions what
do you think about English opening for a
1500 player yeah any mainstream opening
is playable for for 1500 players are
there some traps for lower rated players
their English is one of those things
there's less like concrete lines it's
more about like setups there's still
lines but sometimes players around 1500
level they'll just deviate from theory
very early I'm trying to think of any
traps off the top of my head
there's a game I showed once in a st.
Louis chess club lecture beating a GM
know a super DM in like 12 moves in the
English I'll just show they game real
quick it's a very nice
trapping line go away Java
okay remind me later so it's like one of
the main lines where if black plays g6
here this is something I play in
tournaments like d4 it takes a Knight d5
really cool variation and then a flat
play is the most natural move
I mean Bishop g7 zone ly move than
Bishop g5 was a game car yakin around
raking and raking car yakun
insert this and then basically white one
a white one in ten moves because black
played what looks like a normal move but
then tactics start happening well black
should play is either f6 or night here
but let's imagine let's see what
happened the game denied here there's
beautiful move Knight takes d4 and then
Bishop takes d4 is played if Knight
takes d4 then the Queen is trapped after
a bishop takes d4 a beautiful move Queen
takes d4 because then if the queen is
taken it's mates in two very beautiful
mate and if black castles here which is
really the only try cuz this is a
monster threat then it's some nice
puzzle rush I believe why this meeting
by force 9 f6 now I've shown this to
students and students like we'll play
some random Knight move like Knight h5
and not realize the Queen is hanging so
the winning move here only the only one
winning move is not g4 which sucks the
Queen but again walks into this very
nicely Knight Bishop checkmate so
there's one trap there's more traps
which exists actually I'll show one more
trap which is very near and dear it's my
my hearts another English trap I won't
get the exact move order correctly but
I'll just show the basic idea another
line like this where black plays f5 and
okay this is some kind of mainline
Knight each three here here here here
and then c6 I think this is an exact
position I had it was one of the most
important tournaments I ever played I
was on board two in the second second or
third to last round I was playing a GM
from the United Arab Emirates and it was
a world under 18 championships he just
played he had just played c6 I was so
baffled because he six is just a blunder
white to move in win upon this very
common type of trap that you see in the
French defense put this on YouTube
what do I put on YouTube maybe I'll just
put the whole stream on YouTube people
like that I'll put the whole stream on
YouTube and I'll end it here so people
and the YouTube comments have to comment
your move below that would be
interesting but for the twitch chat
Knight takes e5 is illegal the bishop is
not defended that's true
so the this username tun sees it but
does not have the right notation there
you go I take c4 okay so I got to go
I'll see you guys in the future thanks
for watching